when you go to these various outings
throughout the years do you sort of just
zoom in on someone like go up to them
you just can see that they're going to
be a willing participant sets just come
with I'm just some it's just a 6-ounce I
mean that doesn't happen all the time
but I've been fortunate and lucky that I
that can kind of get a sense of who's
gonna I mean you know if they don't run
from the camera then you you know
they're fair game and there's a good
possibility that they'll share whatever
on camera and but you know people don't
want to be on camera
I don't chase them down or anything or
try to put words in their mouth or or
try to you know you and some of it's
just you just engage people and then you
don't really step on them when they're
talking you don't want to really just
you know step on what they're saying you
just kind of give them a lot of airtime
or just a chance to just say what have
you I mean that was the thing when we
were making the TV show because TV is a
lot different than my independent work
I'll doing a video or documentary or I
can give a lot of air you know there can
be a lot of pregnant pauses what have
you or just for the necessary
you know just breathing space but in TV
it's got to be quick you know they can't
risk losing a potential they can't risk
having somebody change the channel so
when we made the TV series it was cut
much quicker than anything that I would
normally do with my independent work but
I understand that I know the realities
of making television and versus doing
independent documentary so excluding
heavy metal parking lot with these other
projects and not for television but
maybe just the films are you setting out
for like a three-act structure and
you're hoping to you're planning out the
resolution well this goes back to that
point I mean I I tend to not do any
pre-production unfortunately because
sometimes you're just did a loss as how
you're gonna make some
out of what you haven't and I'm I mean
the new film Led Zeppelin played here
has a good story arc that was
miraculously developed but it was not
planned and it just we shot a lot of
material and then have to kind of see it
in the Edit and make sense of it I mean
and then figure out how to tell the
story but I mean that's the first
feature-length project I've done it's
almost 90 minutes long and so you really
have to tell a story if you want people
to not squirm in their seats you have to
really keep them engaged and so I think
we've done it some people would disagree
think it's too long but we've a lot of
people have enough people have responded
positively that I feel okay with the
length and how we went about doing it
but it wasn't planned a lot of the stuff
unfolded and also you know but I if I
did have certain things I wanted to
include or touch on if I was still
interviewing somebody I made sure they
said something that would throw to that
that I could use as a thread connecting
the dots is it's easier if you plan it
really is and if you can't what do you
use as filler you do some b-roll and put
some music absolutely b-roll anything
but you got to just really think for
what the audience is gonna want to sit
through I mean I have do a lot of
talking head interviews and so it's hard
you can't write stuff to show make
people sit for through a talking head
but I but interesting thing I did like I
use a lot of phone interviews in this
film and and so that's interesting to
then try to take or radio I've radio you
know banter and conversation and
interviews on the radio and then also
the phone call interview and so you have
to have some visuals and I you know it's
just it but but some cases the people on
cam on this interview audio are so
charismatic
they really help move this sequence
along so it almost doesn't even matter
what you're showing but you have to have
something to look at but a lot of its
just your trial and error you really
it's and that's kind of the route I
think of what my body of work trial and
error you know that's a good but it
keeps it fun for you oh sure do because
you have the the other job or whatever
the other how much lightness does it
does it bring to you rather than we've
got to get this we've got to get our
investors paid back investors
I should be so lucky yeah I don't have
any real we're I mean I just I like I
don't have very many hobbies I don't
think like conventional like I get on
golf that's I I think golfing is fine
it's a fine pastime but you know it's a
boating they're fine pastimes that take
a lot of time and energy and money but
but I think the time more than anything
or an investment of time and so for me I
put my I spend time doing my projects
and working on these different projects
and building a you know body of work
that I end up sharing online I'm not
quite as prolific these days I want to
just kind of go back and clean up the
shelves with a lot of unfinished
projects but that's what's great about
being able to you know have your own
YouTube channel I just put it up there
and hopefully people will find it
you